hello game chess calm community here are
my five best tips for chess beginners
first of all play as much chest as
possible playing really is the best form
of training that's the way you develop
your instincts
both positional and tactical zone any
playing training is good longer games
blitz games against computers against
other humans secondly reading whether
it's books or content on the internet
like videos watch watching those it
helps - it helps a lot
- to read about chess just because you
like it just because you find it
interesting and in the long run it will
be very helpful number three learn the
basic making techniques like mating with
queen and rook or two rooks and queen
against just the king or also rook
against the king it's very useful useful
to know it gives you a lot of confidence
- that you can that you can finish the
game off with with the mate because
often I especially in games with
beginners you can play very well you can
reach winning position with many pieces
up but it's sometimes hard to checkmate
the opponent and you see in games even
at the very top level the making
techniques of two rooks against a king
and also the medic nick of king and rook
against just the king they are very
useful in many
games number four learn from the old
masters throughout my career I feel that
it's been very useful but most of all
very interesting to read about how chess
has developed over over the years and to
look at the games especially I think the
games since the cup of blood garlic in
much in in 1927 think ever since then
chess has been played at a very high
level and you can learn a lot from all
of the great masters plus of course
again if you're as interested in chess
as I am you will find it very
interesting just to read about it and
lastly but most importantly have fun
chest training practicing it should be
all about having fun if you find playing
long games if you find playing quick
games if you find solving exercises
reading chess books watching videos if
you find all of this they're interesting
and fun you will come a long way